[Musik]
liebe hörerinnen und hörer literatur
kann so anstrengend sei die arbeit an
seinen letzten beiden romanen sei
regelrecht deprimierend gewesen hat
kursen weiter gerade in einem interview
gesagt mit seinem neuen habe er sich
ausgetobt mit underground railroad aus
dem jahr 2016 ist er richtig berühmt
geworden für diesen roman und auch für
nickel boys von 2009 10 hat er den
pulitzer preis bekommen der eine erzählt
eine geschichte der flucht aus der
sklaverei und vor der verfolgung als
habe ist die underground railroad das
geheim netzwerk von fluchthelfern im
amerika der ersten hälfte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts es habe das
tatsächlich aus richtigen schienen
bestanden der zweite roman nickel boys
erzählt von folter und misshandlung in
einer besserungsanstalt wird schwarze
jugendliche in den 60er jahren nach
wahren begebenheiten die erst vor nicht
einmal zehn jahren bekannt geworden sind
als bin auf einem ehemaligen
anstaltsgelände in florida die
verscharrten überreste grausam
zugerichtete jugendlicher fand und jetzt
ein gauner roman wie er selbst sein
neues werk nennt einiges mehr finden wie
es das buch wir sprechen darüber mit
unseren kollegen florian balke das buch
heißt allem schaffen und wir sprechen
natürlich auch bei seinen autor danach
warten noch die neuen antworten auf
unsere drei fragen auf sie liebe
hörerinnen und hörer diesmal kommen sie
von der schriftstellerin antje rávic
strubel erst einmal lieber florian schön
das zurzeit für uns heißt schön mit euch
zu sprechen
colson whitehead mentalem shuffle also
einen gauner roman wird ist ein
zustimmen oder wie würdest du ihn nennen
er ist mehr finde ich geschäftsstelle
darf sein buch so nennen wie er möchte
und
neigen immer mal wieder genauso wie im
der leser die kritikerin die verlegerin
oder im die agentin dazu ein etikett
auszuwählen eine etikette ist bei der
arbeit half eine etikette beim verkauf
hilft das bei bei der inneren anordnung
dessen was man damit machen will dann
hilfreich war und wer sind wir dem auto
zu widersprechen aber trotzdem nur
gaunerkomödie nur gauner roman das
trifft es nicht ganz an werden all das
wird nur angespielt wird angetäuscht
wird genossen wird lustvoll ins
schaufenster gestellt aber das ist der
roman ist viel zu ernst nur da zu sein
das ganze ist ein verfahren das ganze
ist ein das ganze ist eines der vielen
songs die er mit einfließen lässt das
heißt es geht mehr vor sich als an der
oberfläche zu
offensichtlich ist und
genau insofern es geht ganz geht es
darum dass im harem der jahre von 1959
bis 64 verschiedenste einwohner des
viertels sei nicht bloß das tun was sie
haben was sie eigentlich machen sondern
nebenher oder hauptberuflich auch noch
verbrechen begehen aber gerade bei der
hauptfigur geht es darum dass ihr
eigentlich so tut oder zumindest sich
selbst gegenüber der meinung ist hier
mache etwas anderes
er ist jemand der aus einer kaputten
familie kommt der sich selbst dan pro
gearbeitet hat der irgendwann
beschlossen hat sich selbst aufzumöbeln
der so sagt der texte selbst so findet
ray ist selbst und her beschlossen hat
mit der möbelbranche die irgendwie
zufällig über den weg lief um den weg in
ein geregeltes leben ein geordnetes
leben ein schönes leben anzutreten und
er ist daran eigentlich ziemlich
erfolgreich er hat viele kunden an einer
guten ecke in haarlem und hat steht die
kundschaft und bietet gute möbel firmen
an er sehnt sich danach an bestimmte
möbel firmen heranzukommen und vertrete
für diese in sachen zu werden bei la
fontaine die durch jackie kennedy
bekannt wird ist die firma auf diesen am
meisten ankommt ist tot in serie als ein
vertreter in besuch und ein anderes
leben den vertreterbesuch verhagelt wie
ihr leben später dass das ganze aber
doch noch gut geht das heißt dieses der
kampf darum das möbelgeschäft dass sie
irgendwann per entschluss und versetzung
in den lebens schuss gefallen ist
weiterzuführen und als erfolg zu
betrachten ist etwas was was ihn nie
verletzt gleichzeitig ist er von anfang
an ein kleiner jeder beim coaching
freddy erlässt ihnen gelegentlich
geschmuggelte oder in irgendeiner weise
nicht ganz legaler fernseher oder radio
waren oder plattenspieler teilhaftig
werden
und damit fängt es an dann kommt als
eine kleine schmuckstück dazu dann das
andere kleine schmuckstück und abnehmer
findet er in anderen stadtvierteln im
süden manhattans
und bei jüdischen schmuck entlang das
heißt er kommt er so allmählich das dann
eher die station ist wo aus liebe
illegaler ware legal überfahren wird und
das wird aber immer größer dann haben
wir es plötzlich mit einem zu tun und
ray hatte es mit einem raid zu tun um
lehrer auf der einen seite ein ganz
normaler geschäftsmann aus harlem ist ja
leider den fehler hat zu gutherzig zu
sein und zu viele kunden zu viele um
ratenzahlungen zu
lange aus stehen zu lassen und der
andere ray der eigentlich auch aus
notwendigkeit und aus nettigkeit
familienbande es gibt eine nette tante
anblick team auch am herzen denn da
somit reinrutscht dann mit drin hängt
dann mit macht und der auch das spricht
rey am wenigsten außen wir erleben
praktisch alles einem aus seiner
perspektive und in gloriosa
vergangenheitsform und erlebt der rede
um endlich mal kein roman im der immer
nur ich und präsent sagt sondern der
vieles durch erlebte rede spiegelt
wir ja wir sehen wie ihr sehen wie er
daraus dann immer etwas größeres macht
ohne dass er sich so richtig eingestellt
das heißt ist ein freiwillig
unfreiwilliger gauner er möchte sich
eigentlich von der existenz seines
vaters absetzen ja definitiv
ghana war als dann geht es zu beginn
seines lebens ist er möchte mit seinen
mathematik kenntnis mit seinen reichen
kenntnissen mit seinem mit seinen guten
wirtschaftlichen fähigkeiten und mit an
seiner immer intensiveren fähigkeit ein
guter möbelverkäufer zu sein durchkommen
für seine frau für seine kleinen erst
ein kleines dann zwei kleine er möchte
sich auch selbst verbessern er möchte
wir haben auch der immobilien leiter
nach oben klettern er möchte in halle
umziehen er zieht außerdem hinaus an
jetzt angeschafft ist an den riverside
drive zwar noch nicht im fluss blick
sondern mit blick nach hinten hinaus auf
einen berg abhang aber es ist immerhin
der website drive am schluss der für ihn
halbwegs glimpflich ausgeht erleben wir
ihnen dabei aber wo ihr dorthin ziehen
wo er nie hinwollte an die strikers das
ist ein abschnitt in haarlem wo das
schwarze establishment wohnt seine frau
kommen von dort sie ist die tochter
eines rechtsanwaltes und er ist
eigentlich ein ganz anderes milieu und
seine tochter seine seine frau hat nach
unten geheiratet so sehen das zumindest
seine schwiegereltern und
er ist ein geschäftsmann der noch nicht
in dem club ist in dem sein
schwiegervater schon mitglied ist in
diesem club und ein schwarzer
geschäftsleute würden die aufnahme
verweigert später klappt sie dann doch
und das das später dann doch klappt dann
hat etwas damit zu tun dass er im legal
und illegal immer erfolgreicher und
immer wichtiger wird aber wir sehen
ihnen am schluss angeben in den in den
sonnenuntergang reiten mit einem
angestrebten wohnsitz dort wo das
schwarze establishment er wohnt im jahre
64 oder noch etwas später mehr das
bleibt unklar auf den letzten seiten ob
wir uns etwas aus dem jahr schon heraus
bewegt haben und noch etwas sei in die
60er jahre hinein als die als die
einwohnerschaft ahlens in schon
ganz andere sachen machen kann als nur
unternehmer zu sein ihres geschäftsmann
und verbrecher das heißt er hat einen
ganz bestimmten blick auf die unruhen
vom sommer 64 die auf unruhen in den 40
39 erfolgten
und er als geschäftsmann und verbrecher
sieht es wie seine kriminellen kollegen
und seine legalen kollegen anders als
die der jüngeren der studentischen er
aktivistischen kämpfer gegen die
rassendiskriminierung die auch in hagen
bitter zu spüren ist im juli 64 mit
einem schwarzen schüler von einem weißen
polizisten in zivil auf offener straße
erschossen der polizist sagte
der schüler habe ein messer gezückt und
mehrere nächte danach erwartet das stadt
vorstellten zunehmendem aufruhrs
mischten sich immer mehr gruppierungen
an meinen die ihre eigenen agenten
verfolgten und das ganze kam dann aber
mit
der hitze die hitzewelle ging zu ende
der regen setzte ein plötzlich war der
aufstand wieder verpufft aber auf jeden
fall ray und seine geschäftsmänner
kollegen und seinen kriminellen kollegen
sind zwar genauso der meinung wie black
moslems oder andere besonders
aktivistische ganz neue gruppen das ist
dann die tatsache diskriminierung auch
in new york auch in manhattan betrifft
aber da würden sie sich nie mit
einmischen roman im pickup von dieser
auch von diesen nächten des aufruhrs er
erzählt sie nur in der rückblende als
die romane im dritten teil von drei
teilen im juli 64 einsätze sind diese
nächte des aufrufs gerade eben vorbei
gegangen und
der roman verschiebt das ganze in einen
anderen akt der gewalt und zwar in eine
in einen akt ein schwarzer gewalt gegen
weiße preis im kampf gegen meine familie
von bauunternehmern und
immobilienspekulanten mit denen er ist
plötzlich zu tun bekommen hat er mal
über freddy fertig hat sich mit dem
drogensüchtigen schwulen sohn dieser
dynastie aus der partei video
eingelassen das geht über die kräfte von
freddy und von lynas und der sohn der
familie
ende dann eine überdosis in einem miesen
absteiger das heißt aber nicht dass die
familie den schwarzen bekannte des
sohnes lassen würde den sie irgendwann
mal in die elektro schocktherapie
gestellt hat um ihn gesteckt hat und
ihnen von seiner homosexualität zu
heilen dazu sagt einer der charaktere
weise die weiße folter das ist doch mal
eine interessante variante des kampfes
um gleichheit aber nun auf jeden fall
freddy zieht ihn damit hinein und
plötzlich hatte erst mit mit dieser
familie zu tun und mit den verbrechern
die diese familie sich heldt mit den
schergen die sie aussendet um den so
einzufangen um die geschäfte der familie
zu erledigen in einem manhattan in dem
viele viele viele große büro- und
wohngebäude je südlicher ist am morgen
die stadt nach unten geht dieser familie
gehören oder von dieser familie richtet
oder bewirtschaftet werden und plötzlich
hat es ein break ani der kleinere gauner
oder vielleicht auch schon der mittlere
ghana oder vielleicht eher größte
niemand in so nennt ihn ein korrupter
polizist also ein strippenzieher in so
manchem areal zwischen legalem und
illegalem geschäft in hadamar ist mit
meiner familie zu tun die definitiv an
immer größer ist als er das geht aber
auch für ihn eigentlich ganz gut aus
nicht für alle aber für ihn schon und so
sehen wir ihnen am schluss des romans
noch in ihrem leben mit weiteren plänen
aber wie gesagt die entscheidenden juli
tage im jahr 1964 verbringen die leser
kaum mit der mit den unruhen haben die
andere autoren zu einer großen
parallelaktion zu dem was wir in unserer
zeit gesehen haben ausgebaut hätten die
parallelen sind offensichtlich hier ein
weißer polizist der einen schwarzen
schüler auf offener straße erschießen
unserer zeit ein weißer polizist der
sich im minuten lang mit dem knie auf
den hals eines schwarzen verhafteten
stützen all das hätte viel an hätte viel
offensichtlicher angelegt werden können
auf dieses buch ist aber auch ein buch
über unsere zeit das ist es aber dass es
so zu sagen die unauffällige weise so
wie es sich gehört wenn wir das ist an
seinen eigenen weg geht und sie den in
aufruhr links liegen lässt und ein
privater ein privater gegen gewalt
inszeniert die 130 seiten die sich um
die rechte des aufrufs drehen könnten
drehen sich eigentlich vor allen dingen
darum was zwischen ray und seinen von
ihm angeheuerten verbrechern aus seinem
umkreis und den verbrechern im rund um
die familie aus der park avenue abspielt
und so ist es ja nicht nur in diesem
dritten in dieser dritten episode des
buches sondern so ist es auch in diesen
beiden davor das heißt also die das
strukturierende element sind sozusagen
gaunereien in dem buch das nur auf der
oberfläche eingang ein buch ist in dem
ersten teil geht es um den raubüberfall
auf ein legendäres hotel in halle mit
dem zweiten band um die erwähnte um die
rache an einem banker der sein
versprechen bricht für 500 dollar dafür
zu sagen sorgen dass ricanerin so einen
exklusiven club schwarzer
entscheidungsträger würde man heute
sagen aufgenommen wird und dann eben in
diesem dritten teil der kampf gegen
diese einflussreiche familie
diese erzählerische ob diese
erzählerische oberfläche ist sozusagen
dann doch so auf den gauner roman
abgestellt wenn wenn man nur auf die
oberfläche schaut was hältst du von ihr
gut erzählt nicht gut erzählt mitreißend
grenzend erzählt ab lag aber
mit kleinen widerhaken versehen das ist
das ganze ist definitiv kein roman der
auf entspannung setzen würde oder der
design mehrwert daraus bezieht dass hier
sozusagen
eine einer weiteren reinkarnation des
großen alten amerikanischen im themas
davon dass eigentlich alle amerikaner
gauner sind oder das ist eigentlich alle
amerikaner helden sein müssen und es
vielleicht sogar sind dass wir begegnen
so etwas das heißt struktur ist so aber
ist es beginnt immer wieder völlig
unerwartet das verbrechen irgendeinem er
wird von ray nicht gesucht sondern
begegnet ihm so das heißt schräg
irgendwie von links von von der seite
oder von hinten kommt plötzlich irgend
etwas womit er sich auseinandersetzt was
er ein baum muss in sein so wie jemand
ist in eine wohnungseinrichtung einbauen
müsste man muss damit zurechtkommen man
muss es schön gestalten man muss es gut
machen man muss es ja sowieso so gut
erledigen wie eine erfolgreiche
wohnzimmereinrichtung so ungefähr und
das heißt uns so kommt es dann auch aber
wie gesagt wir sind diese ganzen kleinen
widerhaken drin dass wir
wir bewegen uns nicht in einer
atemberaubenden spannungs dramaturgie
obwohl kurzen walter es kosten weiter
sich irgendeinem jede seite jeder absatz
oder ein größerer zusammenhang sehr gut
liest aber wir jammern nicht bloß auf
die nächste wendung eine eine handlung
die sich um verbrechen grausamkeiten und
die die steigerung in diesen kategorien
dreht man hat plötzlich im spaß daran
dass irgendjemand abschweift dass es
plötzlich doch wieder um die familie
geht das ist was ich mir etwas ganz
anderes geht oder dass ich ein jenseits
der gut weg erzählte kleinen episode
aber plötzlich etwas in den vordergrund
schiebt wo man merkt dass es vor allen
dingen gut geschrieben wir haben
plötzlich mitten im bericht über einen
der mit raid von anfang bis ende
befreundeten gauner pepper dann haben
wir eine ausgesprochen schöne sätze in
der rückschau es ist nicht ganz klar im
rahmen dieser rückschau teil hat oder ob
es besser ist oder ob die erzählerstimme
uns das mitteilt aber er ging nicht in
die kirche war seine eigene predigt zwei
sehr kurze sätze wunderschön formuliert
und ein paar seiten weiter der krieg
erwarte im zweiten weltkrieg gekämpft
und veränderte ihn nicht er
komplettierte ihn sind grenzen die
wunderbar kurz inzwischen länger
formulierten passagen stehen leitet hat
ein großes rhythmusgefühl und all diese
sachen wie das ganze angeschrieben ist
die form des ganzen tritt immer mal
wieder in den vordergrund
das begegnet einem natürlich auch in
anderen chronischen am ausformungen
amerikanischer gartner mythen die man
ebenfalls wegen ihrer schönen formalen
erfindungen gut gefunden hat vom parken
in mehreren teilen über das war einmal
in amerika die sind zu rezente und an
beispielen aber wie gesagt das
leseerlebnis ist keine er ist kein
reißerisches ding das dass das uns
sozusagen atemlos von verbrechens
handlung zu verbrechens handlung stürzen
lässt sondern es ist ein kleinteiliger
mosaikartig es verändert die
geschwindigkeit mit der es durch seinen
stoff geht anders als in der großen
verfolgungsjagd in der dann irgendeinen
film gipfeln könnte und der dritte teil
hat etwas davon dass das tempo mächtig
anzieht und das ganze den man mir auf
einen showdown in einem haus zuläuft das
ist sozusagen noch dass ein wo man am
ersten denkt ja das ist jetzt ein
typischer im typischen abfolge von etwas
mit gaunereien verbrechen kriminalfalls
grausamkeit und gewalt zu tun hat aber
ansonsten ist das ganze plötzlich immer
wieder etwas ganz anderes als das was
man noch eine zeile vorher gedacht hat
es ist
definitiv an einem roman von co2 dem
definitiv das genre nur nutzt und sich
eben nicht an heimen gibt das heißt wenn
man etwas erzählt sucht er sich die am
dem stoff angemessene form es geht um
einen mann eine familie viele menschen
eine ganze gesellschaftsschicht um eine
klasse eine rasse die in amerika sich
versucht einzurichten die aber keinen
wirklich bequemen ganz sicheren ort hat
indem sie wichtig unangreifbare zu hause
ist wie im haus mit dem weißem
gartenzaun
es geht darum dass man danach sucht wie
man das erzählen kann verunsicherung
doppelbödigkeit fassaden das was
dahinter liegt das heißt an die prekäre
situation des einen mannes remmel der
sehen musste wo er für seine junge
familie bleibt die er zärtlich liebt
steht irgendwo beispielhaftem steht als
exempel für den versuch wieder menschen
in den 50er und 60er jahren im schwarzen
new york zu hause zu sein das klappt
besser als zu anderen zeiten oder an
anderen orten aber es klappt dann leider
eigentlich doch überhaupt nicht dafür
braucht es dann
jemanden der den mann den man in eine
situation von größter
unübersichtlichkeit fluktuation es kann
so senden ist kann so ende zeigen kann
das heißt
der gauner toplos bietet sich an der
verbrechen stop loss bietet sich an aber
vor allen dingen eben jemand der nicht
eindeutig auf der seite des gartens
steht sondern nahm der sich selbst als
ein mittelsmann sieht sich selbst als
vermittler zwischen mrd kriminellen welt
und nicht kriminellen welt des alltags
normaler menschen sieht der ganz genau
weiß dass er dazwischen steht der aber
auch darauf waren würde nicht ganz zu
unrecht das ihr dazwischen steht und wir
haben es also mit etwas weniger
kriminalität zu tun als bei all den
anderen mafia artigen schwarzen und
weißen verbrechern im den gewinn weg
laufen die mit größter mit wir haben mit
mit größter selbstverständlichkeit
hauptberuflich dem verbrechen nachgehen
aber wie gesagt haben vor allen dingen
die die form muss gefunden werden um das
ganze zu erzählen dass er bedient sich
bei all diesen formen und bei all dem
was du bereit steht wenn man diese
planlos gelesen hat gesehen hat oder
wenn man es war einmal in amerika
gesehen hat wie wir leben den konflikt
von alltag und geheime verbrechens welt
wir erleben dass wir leben die ehefrau
die davon nichts weiß wir erleben das
geheimhalten und das allmählich immer
radikaler werden wir erleben das
ausprobieren den selfmademan auch in
verbrechen wir erleben dass das das
ganze durchaus spaß machen kann und zwar
sowohl denen dies erleben als auch denen
die davon lesen und auch damit spielt
weiter ganz bewusst dass das wir freude
daran haben dass hier jemand nicht bloß
sagen erleidet erduldet opfer ist
gegenstand weißen handelt ganz oben im
norden ist oder auch gegenstand
schwarzen handelns er ist nicht nur ein
subjekt schwarzen handelns er ist auch
ein subjekt von ich bin mein eigener
staat ich bin mein eigener
amerikanischer bürger der gelegentlich
die sachen so regelt wer es regeln will
das heißt irgendwie erleben die
übernahme von rhodia muss für das weiße
amerika gelten für das italienische oft
genug von der angelsächsischen
gesellschaft rassistisch ebenfalls
beiseitegeschoben weiße amerika der
mafia welt aber wir leben plötzlich
schwarze verbrecher auch das ist
sozusagen eine interessante kleine
verschiebung die der roman offenbar
vorzunehmen erwünscht aber wie gesagt es
gehe ist es immer so zu sagen dass das
nutzen von mechanismen oder von
verfahren gauner literatur des romans
über ein verbrechen mit mit leichten
verschiebungen mit leichten ergänzungen
mit einem sachen die uns immer wieder
bewusst machen hier schreibt jemand der
nicht bloß an dem es nicht bloß auf die
handlung ankommt sondern die muss
erstens darauf ankommt wie der satz
formuliert ist welche wörter benutzt
werden und in welchem zusammenhang
dieser roman geschrieben worden ist und
in welchem zusammenhang wie ihn lesen er
ist kein roman unserer gegenwart es geht
nicht um irgendwelche zeitlosen
verbrechen wie so viele grün ist es sich
erlauben das könnte irgendwie trotz
regionaler verankerung von schweden bis
zur englischen provinz ja eigentlich
auch immer und überall spielen der
mensch ist böse dieses buch ist
erfolgreich im du liest es gerne dieses
buch hier deutet das antik das an aber
es ist ein historischer roman und das
sorgt für eine gewisse distanzierung
sowohl in richtung auf unmittelbare
anwendbarkeit auf das was unsere zeit
betrifft obwohl es natürlich ein buch
ist das zu den jahren dem ungeheuren
erfolg von blättern als mieter nach in
einer riesigen anzahl von todesfällen
mit einem weißen knien auf schwarzen
felsen oder weißen waffen
die gerichtet sind auch den rücken oder
auf die brust von schwarzen männern
natürlich irgendeinem sagt das buch
jederzeit ich bin ein buch auch über das
jahr 2020 das jahr 2009 10 das jahr 2021
aber gleichzeitig ist dieses auto schon
immer erfolgreich gewesen im ausstatten
als 110 ob sie im 19 jahrhundert
spielten oder im mittleren zwanzigsten
jahrhundert gegen die richtung dass das
man sehr sehr sehr dort ist dass man
sehr genau spürt er mit ganz ökonomisch
erzählten details die ganz weniger
reichen aus um dann dass sich die welt
in der die figuren von gegengelesen
bewegen vorstellungen zu lassen das
klappt auch hier wieder glänzend das
kann ja super und aber darüber hinaus
ist das ganze eben auch eine
distanzierung merkmal das niemals ist
dieser roman was affirmativ oder
problemlos liga tores in irgendeiner
weise das heißt er ist dann gleichzeitig
immer vieles oder hintereinander sehr
vieles unterschiedlicher und habe ich
würde gerne mal kurz ein haken du hast
die chance über die schönen sätze und
die gutgeschrieben und glänzende sprache
gesprochen
wir kriegen das ganze in einer
übersetzung nämlich von nikolaus stingl
präsentiert kannst du ein paar worte zu
der übersetzung sagen wie kamen sie die
vorhut holprig damit haben sie gut vor
es ist als zeichen von mmm von
freundlichem dieser engagement an
zu lesen dass man bei antiken hatte ihn
nicht verändert oder also dieser einsatz
ich habe ihnen mehr augenblick nicht
ganz exakt im kopf aber im krieg hat er
nicht beendet er komplettierte ihn da
hatte ich plötzlich das gefühl irgendwie
so in dem wir nicht vollendet aber
das heißt man geht gelegentlich mit an
und denkt sich wie findet man das aber
im grossen ganzen hat mir die
übersetzung sehr gut gefallen und sie
übersetzt auch das ist also sie nimmt
auch die herren die anwärter mit die
leitet selbst benutzt an falls wir
darüber noch reden wollen ja also ich
empfand die übersetzung als gelungen und
als transparent man sieht den stoff man
sieht das material man sieht die
verfahren das was bei ihnen so wichtig
ist in jedem buch aber in diesem umso
mehr weil es mal wieder so zu sagen so
ein so einen gang in eine ganz neue
richtung ist das was an das was ihn
immer auszeichnet also sein material
sein thema und seine formen so geschickt
zu wählen das ist im anschluss findet
man an zeitgenössische themen an etwas
was auch im augenblick aktuell ist aber
etwas was auch eine schwarze geschichte
rettet oder wieder bewusst macht
episoden oder große epochen die einen
bestimmten details obwohl man den
bürgerkrieg mittlerweile jedoch auch im
jahre 2021 in deutschland irgendwie ganz
gut kennt und auch diese zustände vor
dem bürgerkrieg trotzdem auch dort ist
das immer noch dass das retten von
unbekannte um das retten von halb
vergessenen das retten von nie ganz
bekannten oder das retten von etwas
schon allzu bekannten vor der
automatisierung um die idee von der
underground railroad als wirklich
existieren da im untergrund eisenbahn
ist ein typisches beispiel für das was
die russischen kommunisten oder was vor
ihnen auch schon
als die testautomatisierung der
wahrnehmung kommen beim unterzeichneten
etwas was die literatur
unbedingt machen muss immer wieder geht
es darum dass wir nicht einfach nur
hinsehen und dasselbe sehen wie immer
also den bürgerkrieg um die sklaverei
sondern dass wir ganz neu hinsehen und
dass wir den gegenstand frisch poliert
wie in race möbelladen in dem alles
glänzt und in dem alles recht gerückt
wird sehen dass wir ihnen und all seiner
grausamkeit sehen wie in underground
railroad die sklaverei die tatsache dass
das diese untergrundbahn plötzlich als
wirkliche metro unter der erde die
jemand gegraben haben muss die von
bestimmten orten zu bestimmten orten
verläuft sehen erinnert uns viel
nachdrücklicher daran was es zu
entkommen gilt als wenn wir
einen roman lesen würden in dem diese
fantastische geniale geste nicht gemacht
worden wäre gibt es denn diesmal auch
solche fantastischen gesten nein dieser
dieses dieses ein bedingt wird so nicht
wiederholt aber letztlich kann man den
griff zur kriminalhandlung als parallele
nehmen auch das hier wie gesagt ist
eingriff in ein anderes genre ist ein
eingriff in ein neues genre ist das
einlassen auf bestimmte konventionen es
gibt jemanden der verbrechen begeht es
gibt jemanden es gibt etwas was
gestohlen werden soll es gibt etwas was
von hand zu hand geht was den eigentümer
gewechselt dort kommen die topoi das
möbelgeschäft und das verbrechen
zusammen es geht es ist ein umbau im
eigentum es ist ein roman um möbel ist
ein roman um immobilien es ist ein roman
um menschliche gier es ist ein roman
aber auch um eigentum ist um die
eigentumsbildung um den verlust von
eigentum wie starten wir uns unsere
erste als schwarzes ehepartner sein kind
bekommt
dann geht um vielleicht ein sofa zu
kaufen es vielleicht auf raten doch noch
sich leisten zu können wie starten wir
unser erste eigene wohnung aus wie leben
wir von dort an weiter was bleibt nach
unseren tod an möbeln zurück irgendetwas
geschieht damit das heißt so beginnt es
und macht allmählich klar
auf eine manchmal sehr sehr elegant nur
angedeutete weise manchmal auf eine eben
auch bewusst ausgestellte weise um
bewusst zu halten dass das ganze eine
geformte handlung ist eine geschriebene
handlung um eine bewusst an einem
geformte handlung und kunst nicht
wirklichkeit immer wieder wird klar dass
das ganze leben ein roman über eigentum
ist und wie man es schnell verlieren
kann wie es einen geraubt werden kann
bis hin zum eigentum des lebens dass ein
mir nichts dir nichts geraubt werden
kann in solchen begriffen in diesem in
diesem wort fällt dort dann kommt das
ganze zusammen und dazu ist der griff
zum glas stoff natürlich in der tat an
frische und an ein unerwartet bei
anwohner wartbarkeit mit dem genialen
trick von underground railroad um das
ganze zu einer wirklichen sache zu
machen im erfunden im kontext durchaus
zu vergleichen aber ich
fand
ich kann sehr lustig bei dem buch das
alle die schutzgelderpresser die beim
reinkommen
die gauner die ihn mit ins boot geholt
haben ob er wollte oder nicht und
natürlich ganz viele gelegenheitskunden
auch den laden nicht verlassen ohne dann
irgendwie doch noch mal mit dem blick an
irgend einer anrichte hängen zu bleiben
oder irgendeinem ruhesessel und dann mit
ihm ins geschäft kommen letzten endes
also selbst pepper der irgendwie einer
der härtesten härtesten knochen ist über
die ich gelesen habe der lässt sich dann
irgendwie so ein ruhesessel von ihm
überreichen als
lohn für seine dienste in einer
bestimmten geschichte ich hab s ich habe
das buch auch gelesen als sozusagen ein
porträt dieses stadtteils als ein
porträt harems in den späten 50ern
frühen 60ern und hat dann zu meiner
überraschung gelesen das kurzem weiter
dort nie gewohnt hat dass er da zwar
viel rum gelaufen ist für sein buch aber
das ja erst jetzt 20 21 und dass er
eigentlich nur mit einer 5 prozent regel
arbeitet wie er selbst sagt also fünf
prozent muss der wirklichkeit
entsprechen und mit dem rest für fährt
er so nach belieben dabei habe ich ihm
diese zahlen damals geglaubt total ich
weiß ist es dir auch so gegangen florian
ja absolut ist dass es ist auch dort ist
es auch dort man man man liest weil er
seine bücher so viele bücher
gleichzeitig sind ja und sich nicht nur
auf ein bestimmtes kunststück verlassen
sondern viele kunststücke
innerhalb ihrer 300 oder 400 seiten
aufführen können es und er wiederholt
sich ja eben auch nie sondern er möchte
uns jedes mal etwas neues präsentieren
weil seine bücher in so sind amüsiert
man sich lacht grinst lächelt über
solche sehen der polizist geht raus
damit etwas
bekommt so ein ruhesessel dabei
irgendwie ist nichts gegensätzlich als
papa und 1 uhr sessel aber es ist eben
auch karitativ tätig er lässt nicht nur
ratenzahlungen sondern empfindet auch
das möbel heraus dass
leute verdient haben so ungefähr und es
sind solche ausstattungsdetails die man
ihm ebenfalls unbedingt abnimmt die sind
so klug gewählt aber es ist auch nicht
so dass das dass das ganze rum dass das
ganze roman gebäude nur so von ihnen
stürzen würde
also die die erzählte welt wird nicht
mühsam aus gepinselt und sozusagen in
panorama fenster für uns aufgeräumt oder
mit unglaublichen rekord produkten über
ihre morris tapeten es ist ein detail
hier ein detail dort eingeteilt das mag
manchmal muss für die eigene szene
gelten auch wie in underground railroad
etwas was das gesamte buch durchzieht
ist auch dort das eigentums thema
nämlich dass an dem kleinen garten
inzwischen den baracken
im vierten teil der plantage von der
chora feed ein garten den sie von ihrer
mutter schon erhalten hat ein ganz
kleines stückchen land auf den sie auf
dem auch ihre mutter schon etwas gezogen
hat auf dem auch sie noch etwas ziehen
will um das gekämpft wird als sie sich
im entschließt sich von deren von der
plantage zu fliegen
dh es sind es gibt bestimmte orte
bestimmte szenen bestimmte figuren mit
bestimmten details die das ganze buch
über oder sogar elektro hinaus
unvergesslich bleiben weil sie mit einem
wohl ausgewählten detail oder mit zehn
wohl ausgewählten details ausgestattet
wurden 10 sind schon viel und das trägt
aber dazu bei und weil sie genau dort an
einem vorkommen wo sie wo sie besonders
gut wirken wo sie besonders bemerkbar
sind
dass das das dass man das gefühl hat es
ist das handeln der 50 er ist das 60 das
ich erlebe das amerika der sechziger das
amerika der fünfziger es kann eine
automarke sein ist können die möbel
marken sein ist es ist ein kleines
kleidungs detail ist ein witterungs
detail es ist ein stimmungs geruchs
atmosphäre im detail das heißt eine
ganze menge ist möglich und das ganze
wird wie gesagt immer wieder in sehr
gereift erzählt sie ökonomisch sehr
sparsam erzählt
es ist nicht so dass die das ausmalen
des schwarzen harlems der fünfziger und
sechziger jahre zwischen haben relations
und bürgerrechtsbewegung jetzt deck des
buches wäre oder das hintergrundrauschen
aber wie gesagt auch das mannschaft ist
man hat das gefühl man liest einen roman
auch über diese zeit und über eine
bestimmte menschengruppen und das stimmt
schon so
bestimmt vielleicht gerade darum weil
man innerhalb von dem harem und dass es
geht diesen habe inzwischen
bürgerrechtsbewegung und die haare
nations als das weiße amerika
kenntnissen haben vorbeischaute dann
auch wieder abbaute und nach links
liegen ließ in unglaublich
unterschiedliche personen aufgespaltet
ist wir leben das nicht irgendwie eine
größere ansammlung von leuten ist die
immer das gleiche empfinden fühlen
erleben und tun sondern wir leben eine
große menschenmenge von völlig
widerstreitenden interessen männer und
frauen kinder und alte großeltern enkel
kinder
hier eine wirtschaftliche handlung dort
die versuche von ein bisschen alltags
glück es wird gekocht ist wird dann
etwas gelesen es wird etwas gekauft es
wird etwas verkauft aber all diese leute
haben völlig unterschiedliche ansichten
und er sind in keiner weise über einen
kamm zu scheren und auch das schafft er
dadurch dass
es kommen unglaublich viele leute vor
aber das würde man anderen romanen auch
er anmerken oder es wäre das erste was
man über sie sagen würden mensch was für
ein großer kaarst das fällt einem
irgendwann ihr zwischendurch auf und ist
aber auch von ihm so nebenbei erledigt
das unglaublich viel wird durch kleine
ställen untergebracht unter anderem eben
auch
ein großes menschenbild ein wimmelbild
dass ich eben auch auf ganz manhattan
ausweitet in andere bundesstaaten
ausgreift im zweiten weltkrieg auch auf
die ganze welt ausgereift aber immer
bloß für eine halbe seite für zwei
sätzen oder so etwas und insofern genial
anwalt ist eben dass er all diese
verschiedenen romane die ihr
gleichzeitig schreibt in einem roman
zusammenfasst und sie sich nicht
verdrängen sondern alle miteinander
spielen und
das ja also so wirft die eingestellte
sich mit der anderen stelle freundlich
den ball zu und den leser zur freude der
leserin zu vergnügen aber es ist
eigentlich
immer nur eine sache sondern es ist
kinder mindestens zehn sachen
gleichzeitig von diesen vielen vielen
themen und personen und dingen und was
da alles an getippt wurde was hast du
denn so mitgenommen als das was die
nächsten gegangen ist was nicht am
meisten beschäftigt hat was dir
irgendwie von diesem buch bleibt auch
das sind mehrere sachen zum einen
zum einen der eindruck was habe ich eben
für ein unglaublich gut geschriebenes
buch gelesen das geht einem wirklich
nicht bei jedem buch so dass man liest
zum anderen die hauptfigur als gestalt
es gibt im hauptfiguren die mehr platz
im buch einnehmen die das die alles
weitere die die alles an die seite
drängen er bleibt im eigentlich stein
unter vielen bleibt ein strang unter
vielen auch wenn er alles zusammenhält
und das die erzählerstimme trotzdem
immer wieder sich erlaubt überall
hinzugehen von seinem bewusstsein aus
von seiner wahrnehmung aus von seiner
wiedergabe aus aber eher als figur des
dazwischen dass diese sehr sehr viel
deutlicher roman mit seinen mehrdeutigen
stellen mit referenten stellen mit
seiner ambivalenten passagen eine solche
hauptfigur hat ist vermutlich zwingend
oder passend aber trotzdem oder gerade
weil hier jemand ist der dazwischen
steht zwischen diesem und jenem und dann
noch zwischen dem und dem zwischen
mordtat und ja ich komme nach hause und
spiele mit meinen kindern und einem
empfang meine schwiegereltern mit denen
ich mich auch immer nicht verstehen aber
auch zwischen klein anfangen und ganz wo
anders enden diese sehr vielschichtige
figur mir sehr gut gefallen aber
insgesamt ja das ganze als mosaik das
ganze als als roman der ein als als lisa
niemals langweilt niemals loslässt immer
überrascht der nicht der auf der einen
seite etwas ganz anderes macht als auch
den nächsten das heißt ungeheuer
abwechslungsreich und zwar nicht
von harry potter oder gang of four
sondern einfach durch das wie er gemacht
ist der erzählt es der
große roman kunst die uns zeigt wie wie
bewegliche man sein muss als ein autorin
oder als autor wie beweglich man sein
kann um auf dem niveau zu landen woher
mit diesem roman den letzten beiden
gelandet ist sich nie zu wiederholen
oder nur bewusst zu wiederholen immerhin
motive wiederholen sich bei ihnen sehr
gerne sie kommen 400 seiten später
wieder sie kommen zwischendurch auch mal
wieder ein leicht verschobene form das
heißt das ganze ist unglaublich
sorgfältig gewebt gehört zusammen es
verweist aufeinander es ist eine in
genialer prosa
eine geradezu dichterische fähigkeit zur
verteidigung der bestandteile des textes
zueinander in relation so dass man mit
wenigsten mit wenigen worten das ist das
meiste aus sagen kann ja das ist das was
dann was mich ein buch am meisten
beeindruckt hat und was der deutlichste
eindruck ist die geniale art die geniale
mache aus dass das wirklich ist wirklich
gut geschriebene buch beispielhaft für
für
wünschenswert wäre das ist beispielhaft
wäre für sehr viele antworten alle die
einem so als leser oder ist kritik über
den weg gelaufen war im schaffen von
colson whitehead ist gerade bei hanser
erschienen wurde übersetzt von nikolaus
stingl hat 384 seiten und kostet 25 euro
und wir sagen vielen dank für deine
einschätzung und ausführungen über
florian ich danke euch
[Musik]
unsere drei fragen zu schreiben und
lesen haben wir diesmal der
schriftstellerin antje rávic strubel
gestellt gerade ist sie mit ihrem
jüngsten roman blaue frau der gerade
erst bei s.fischer erschienen ist für
den deutschen buchpreis nominiert
die erste frage lautet warum sie
schreibt ich schreibe eigentlich aus
ganz verschiedenen gründen also es gibt
nicht nur ein grund auch wenn ich am
anfang dachte es geht nur ein aber also
ein ein wichtiger grund ist dass ich ein
tiefes bedürfnis habe im rhythmus der
sprache zu sein also in dieser bewegung
von wort zu wort dieser in diesem fluss
der beim schreiben entsteht also mit
getragen zu werden wenn die sprache
einen park das ist so ein wenn es sehr
gut geht dann versetzt mich dass in so
einen rauschzustand und man ist so ganz
erfüllt also ja fast außer sich quasi
ein bisschen wie im jahr wie im rausch
das zweite ist eigentlich so ein
vergnügen an der architektonischen
gestaltung eines romans also ich glaube
jeder roman ist ein ganz eigenes bauwerk
und wenn ich an einem roman arbeitet und
so ein stoff oder ein thema habt dann
muss ich mir natürlich überlegen
was ist diesem stoff als gehäuse quasi
angemessen oder wie kommt dieser stoff
in der konstruktion des ganzen irgendwie
am besten zum tragen und das macht mir
großes vergnügen und ein drittes was
eigentlich auch schon immer da war was
ich aber wahrscheinlich vorher vor
einigen jahren nie so gesagt hätte ich
will natürlich die welt verändern
also
ich glaube ja irgendwie dass jedes
kunstwerk auf irgendeine weise ein
bisschen die welt verändert und
ich wenn ich wenn ich mir anschaue was
ich so gemacht habe und was ich mache
dann sehe ich doch dass ich geschichten
andere geschichten erzählen will oder
geschichten anders erzählen will und den
blick vielleicht auf dinge lenken möchte
die entweder brach liegen oder die nicht
gesehen werden obwohl sie vielleicht
sogar vor aller augen ganz offen
darlegen und das ebenfalls ins
bewusstsein holen und weil es einfach
ins bewusstsein unserer gesellschaft wir
haben gerade von der welt verändernden
kraft von kunst auch von büchern
gesprochen auch von büchern die sie
schreiben oder der hoffnung dass bücher
diese kraft auch haben
wie ist es bei ihnen selbst gibt es ein
buch das für sie die welt verändert hat
oder dessen lektüre ihren blick auf die
welt oder ihren blick auf sich selbst
verändert hat
je nach einem einzigen buch jetzt zu
fahren
es passiert ja immer wieder
ich bin immer sehr beglückt wenn ich
irgendwie bücher finde wo ich sachen
finde die ich vorher noch nie so gelesen
habe oder die
sprachlich auf eine weise geschrieben
sind was ich vorher noch nicht erlebt
habe
ich habe ihn manchmal ein bisschen
fast traurig wenn ich mir überlege dass
ich vielleicht bestimmte bücher schon
viel früher im leben hätte entdecken
können weil ich habe irgendwie
festgestellt dass ich als ich aufwuchs
sehr häufig oder fast ausschließlich
bücher von männlichen autoren gelesen
haben seltsamerweise vielleicht gar
nicht so setzt haben und viele
autorinnen mir dadurch eigentlich
entgangen sind die ich eigentlich erst
viel später entdeckt habe also wenn ich
zum beispiel carson mccullers figur der
frankie sagen wir mal mit 12 13 14
entdeckt hätte dies aus dem roman the
member of the wedding auf deutsch heißt
da glaube ich denke ich auch im titel
dann hätte ich beispielsweise buch wie
effi briest von fontane mit größerem
vergnügen gelesen als ich in der schule
dann tatsächlich gelesen hab weil dann
weiß seine parallele zwischen diesen
beiden hauptfiguren gibt also fränk ist
ein sehr androgynes junges mädchen und
wenn man sich fontane effi briest darauf
daraufhin dann anschaut dann sieht man
dass er eigentlich es ist eigentlich
eine frühe tomboy gestalten der
deutschen literatur ist also dabei
sollte es fällt mir gerade ein bei
solchen sachen
er hätte ich manches gerne schon früher
entdeckt und hätte dann vielleicht schon
vorher bestimmte ideen gehabt oder per
vorbilder gehabt oder dergleichen
in letzter zeit hat mich sehr wenn ja wo
es beeindruckt muss ich sagen die ich
auch viel zu spät angefangen hab zu
lesen also
ja ihre essays und gerade habe ich zum
leuchtturm gelesen und bin völlig platt
also da sind einfach so sagen so
einschlagen und dann ist man sehr bin
ich sehr begeistert ja
bei dieser bei diesem wunsch mit diesem
wunsch ein buch früher gelesen zu haben
verbindet man ja manchmal diese fantasie
man könnte einem jüngeren ich ein buch
empfehlen da haben ja gibt es so was was
sie ihrem jüngeren nicht empfehlen
wollten
ja ohne dialog us-amerikaners natürlich
sowieso
und dann tja
so ein buch wie mittel mal zum beispiel
von george eliot
wäre auch eine gute wäre auch eine gute
alternative gewesen zu diesen ganzen
französischen realistischen roman durch
die ich mich also auch als ich jünger
war irgendwie manchmal gequält manchmal
begeistert durchgelesen habe also was er
sich bei tag oder ego dann wäre george
eliot auch mal eine interessante in
andere sichtweise oder eine andere ja
noch mal eine andere herangehensweise
gewesen also mittelmark auf jeden fall
die habe ich auch viel zu spät ist dort
habe ich auch viel zu spät entdeckt
[Musik]
falls sie liebe hörerinnen und hörer die
autorin und ihr jüngstes buch jetzt
näher kennenlernen wollen am dritten
september ist antje rávic strubel mit
blaue frau zu gast beim großen longlist
abend in der freien akademie der künste
in hamburg und am vierten september
liest sie im rahmen der deutsch
israelischen kulturtage im literaturhaus
berlin aus ihrem roman und am 13
september ist sie auch im literaturhaus
frankfurt zu gast tags darauf in der
buchhandlung geistes blüten in berlin
und später wieder im september in
dresden und in hannover
am 21 september
shortlist zum deutschen buchpreis
bekannt gegeben und am 18 oktober
schließlich der preisträger oder die
preisträgerin
dieses jahres
[Musik]
in den schoß und auf unserer seite
www.kath.net
bücher - podcast bücher mit finden sie
liebe hörerinnen und hörer florian
waalkes rezension von halem shuffle noch
einmal zum nachlesen weitere artikel zu
werken von kurzen leitet und von und
über anti radek stube wenn sie uns
schreiben wollen sie erreichen uns unter
podcast der vz punkt.de bücher mit ihm
auch diesmal wenn sie uns abonnieren
wollen oder licon oder sonst was in den
podcast an ihrer wahl oder bei instagram
wo wir uns gerade über die ersten 800
abonnenten freuen dort heißen wir faz
bücher bücher mit
vielen dank fürs zuhören auch diesmal
und bis bald bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]